ladies and gentlemen boys and girls back
by popular demand
our favorite 12 year old in the entire
world
benjamin benjamin how are you
hi i'm doing great how are you i'm doing
fantastic
uh
i have a couple questions are you still
12 years old
13 now
you get you're getting older man all
right 13 years old that means we just up
our expectations of what you're gonna do
in the world uh give us an update last
time we talked you had launched uh weird
whales and you had made a couple hundred
thousand dollars uh in doing so
i have heard through the internet that
things have gotten much much better
what's going on with weird whales
so a little status on weird wells so the
project has now traded
around 2000 east which is over 5 million
dollars and the mind-blowing thing is
that it only cost me around three
hundred dollars to build using open soft
software
are you out here
are you flexing on people saying they
only spent three 300 and you had five
million dollars in trading in weird
whales
yes
all right and so when you think of it
why why are you still working on this
like what are you learning why is this
interesting to you
nfts are just we're only at the start
of a 10-year revolution
that 99 of nft use cases are waiting to
be discovered so it might seem
completely out of this world that monkey
jpegs are selling for millions of
dollars but the real use cases will come
in five to ten years from now
and i'm here with nfts to stay all right
and i know that you're working on a
whole bunch of different stuff and now
like i feel like you're kind of like me
right like you started trying to do
something it started to work you put
some more effort in it worked a little
bit more then you're like alright this
might really work now you got five
million dollars of trading volume you're
probably the richest 13 year old in the
entire world the whole nine yards uh and
so now you've started to think like well
what else can i do before we talk about
that
did you take a run at naming your school
after yourself do you remember last time
we talked have you looked into that at
all
i have had shower thoughts about it but
i haven't really gone ahead with it
you had shower thoughts about naming the
school after yourself
yes you should just do it you should do
it how much would it cost you should you
should go talk to the principal and say
hey i'd like to make a donation to the
school how much would i have to donate
in order to change the name of the
school and then once you get that number
dm me on twitter and we'll figure out
maybe we'll uh we'll chip in uh a whole
three dollars to uh alongside your 250
grand to rename the school after 300 you
might turn into five million in trading
yeah or we'll invest 300 and you give us
5 million back
yeah i'd love to do that but the
surprising thing is that school fees are
basically the amount of money i made
last year
all right talking to me about these uh
non-fungible films what is that i know
that's something that you're like you're
super interested in
yes so i'm working on a few projects
right now and i'll talk about two of
them one is non-fungible films
and
it's changing the way consumers engage
with entertainment and it's just
disrupting hollywood
we have a licensing agreement with two
collections
one is nf heroes which is another nft
collection i worked on with the designer
from marvel and hd board apes to create
an animated series
and this week we also announced our
board
and included two former studio heads
from companies like
cbs and xbox and also the head of a fund
which has raised millions from a16z
and i think
yeah we're minting our mint pass on
april the 25th and there's lots of stuff
happening over all right hold on hold on
back up for a second so non-fungible
film you basically went and you signed
licensing deals with some board apes you
signed some licensing deals uh with
these other collections you literally
built the board of intelligent adults
who now work for you basically and
you're going to create films using the
iep from these collections
yes so i'm a web 3 advisor on that
project and it will start i didn't start
up the project originally it was started
up by a hollywood actor cameron mullen
got it um yeah and so when you think of
that when you think of that the idea is
the final product is going to be a movie
using the intellectual property from
these collections
yes so we aim to do movies tv series
branch out into gaming
i got it okay and then talk to me about
this uh the second idea this like
fintech work in fintech
yes so
i'm also working on work in fintech and
it's a corporate sponsorship scheme so
i'm working with yin chao who's the
former head of digital at barclays bank
and the overall aim is to
sell nfts to corporate clients and then
use that money to educate young people
about web 3 and fintech and then shift
them off to high paying jobs in the
crypto space
bro did you hear what he just said he's
going to take nfts he's going to go to
the corporations and he's going to say
i'm 13 years old i want to sell you an
nft and the corporation's like oh we
have to do good in the world okay how
much is it it's gonna be some
astronomical price he's gonna sell it to
the corporations he calls it a
corporate sponsorship scheme so you
immediately know that he's scheming and
he's gonna take that money and he could
pocket it which all of us would be like
wow you duped the corporations but
instead they're going to take it and
they're going to help these young people
by help fund a whole bunch of different
things to launch careers in the crypto
sphere and so literally robin hood yeah
he he's literally
he's raiding the corporate coffers
and leaving them a little instead of a
candy on the pillow at the hotel he's
leaving them an nft he's taking the
money he's gonna go help young kids
start look at look at his face he's like
that's exactly what i'm doing
[Laughter]
yeah we already have some big names on
board can you
don't tell me any of the names i feel
like you're not allowed to say the names
yet or are you
i can't say anything yet all right
that's fine uh all right now all this is
like pretty crazy right so you launched
your nft project you've done five
million dollars in volume you're doing
the film as an advisor you've got the
scheme to uh to to separate corporations
from their cash the whole thing
and then
he's 13. he went he spoke at oxford and
he was the youngest speaker in almost a
thousand years at oxford
to me that's ever
a thousand years i just say that's ever
that what did you talk about at oxford
i talked about my art journey in the
crypto and nft space and it was an
amazing experience the audience was
really receptive
were they like hey can i get a job were
they asking you to come work for you
well
maybe i had some in my dms after but
in my dms after
can you imagine you work your ass off
your entire life you get all the way to
oxford
and then you literally go to a speech
and afterwards you're like damn i'm
about d i'm a 13 year old for a job
that's a testament to you right that
literally age doesn't matter we talked
about this last time like age does not
matter as long as you can provide value
to the world you can do anything right
yes
all right then then after oxford you
know that wasn't enough in 900 a
thousand years the youngest speaker ever
uh you went to nfc summit in london what
uh what was that
yes so
it was in lisbon actually and it was my
first conference and it was an amazing
experience i also talked about my art
journey in the nft space there as well
and
i was the youngest speaker there as well
surprisingly
joe john what questions you guys got
is this what you want to do when you get
older like what was your plan beforehand
i i assumed that you maybe at some point
you thought about what you would want to
do when you get older and nfts uh
obviously haven't been around for for
13 years or so long uh how has that
changed and is this what you want to do
now
so i
i'm just interested in programming i've
been programming since the age of five
my dad would often come home bring out
his laptop and start coding and he
realized that we were curious so he
started teaching us and that led me to
the nft space
and
i absolutely love nfts and i definitely
want to stick close to nfts and crypto
in the long term
john what questions you got benjamin can
you help me understand um the utility
nft stuff makes sense to me can you
understand all this hype around the
board apes and all these like cultural
nfts
yes so i've thought about this and
with art it's always about the artist or
the story behind the art
so there was a painting called the
bridge by robert ryman and it soared for
around 20 million dollars
and it was just a blank white canvas and
it's easy to say oh i could just do that
but it was the artist and the story
behind
painting a blank white canvas that
attracted the buyers and this is similar
to nftr as well
most artworks get sold because of the
story behind the art or the artist
with the board apes the story was there
were all these crypto whales they had
lots of their time on their hands and
lots of money
and buying into a board 8 would help you
connect with other crypto whales and
give you access to events and this
membership club and that's why most
people buy into these collections gotcha
so tell me about the nft market in
general you you guys want a little
surprise yeah let's hear it a little
surprised benjamin and i've been we've
been cooking in the kitchen we've been
cooking we've been cooking up some stuff
lately yeah yeah we haven't been
scheming ourselves we're going to
separate youtube from the [ __ ] no
picture showing uh what we're going to
do is we're going to bring him on like
every other week or so and he's going to
give us just an update on what the hell
is going on here so what what what is
going on in uh in the nft world right
now i don't spend any time on nft so
you're gonna be my expert
nfts are still booming and it's still
very very early
so on today's show i want to look at
three statistics from open seat which is
the largest nft platform
the first one is dollar sales volume
second one is nft sold and then i'll
finish on active traders all right so
i'll have a look at dollar sales volume
first
open c sales volume in march 2022 was
2.5 billion dollars yes billion not
million
and back last year in march 2021 it was
150 million dollars so it's done a 15x
in one year
and surprisingly march 2022 was actually
quite low compared to january 2022. the
openc sales volume in january was five
billion dollars
double the sales volume in march and
january 2022 was the highest ever sales
volume opencv has ever seen
that's wild
yeah
he's like yeah that is real wild
all right what's the next one
so i'll have a look at nft sold now all
right the amount of nft sold in march
was 1.8 million
in march of 20 in march of 2021
2022 okay and that was
quite low compared to january which was
2.5 million and that was the highest
amount of nfts ever sold on openc and
january was the first time openc did
more than 2.5 million sales got it so if
we think about this uh in march of 2021
there's 150 million in sales by a year
later march 2022 there was 2.5 billion
but even though there was that massive
increase there was still 2.5 million
sales in january of 2022 but by marshall
it's down to 1.8 so even though it's
going down there's still this massive
growth year over year
yes yeah it's pretty crazy
yeah it's really crazy
all right what's the last one
active traders is the last one so in
march 2022 there were 450 000 active
traders
and
that's nothing compare that to the 20
million traders using robin hoods or the
hundreds of millions of marvel and
disney fans
nft was two early days
so 450 000 active traders uh in the
month of march and if you compare that
to you know coinbase or whatever uh it's
still a very small number
yes yeah it's pretty crazy
what's going on with your friends any of
your friends into this stuff
not really they don't really talk about
it much but congratulated me at the time
yeah they want to tell everyone that
they know you probably yeah yeah what
about your brother how is your brother
my brother's one year older than me so
he's 14. what's he doing
yeah so we're both
devs we're both programmers we've both
been coding from a very young age i
think i was five and he was six when he
started coding
and he's
just as good developer as me if not
better and in the long term i want to do
an infrastructure business with my
brother which is where the real
opportunities are at yeah i'm already an
investor in that one remember i told you
i'm in
are you gonna do it
well i'm not gonna focus too much on her
business ideas if you try to think of
one you always think of rubbish ones i'm
just going to keep on learning keep on
programming and hopefully a problem will
come to me that i can solve
all right when you find the problem then
you're going to call me right
yes because you know you know why i want
to invest
what
one i want you to be successful right i
think it would be cool and uh
life-changing for you and your brother
all that but two is i wanna go tell all
my friends i backed a 13 year old we
took over the world y'all stupid
right i feel like there's a lot of
things that go into building a company
that if you're 13
you actually have an advantage over
older people like you could call up any
ceo
and say hey i'm 13 i have my own
business i'd like to come meet with you
to talk about you know abc uh d thing
and there's a lot of ceos be like what
like yeah let's go set up the meeting
right and they would take it because
they would want to meet you just as much
as you want to meet them
yeah it's the age is a really big thing
that's what caught all the headlines
that i was in and all the media coverage
i got yeah how much money you made on
this stuff now are you allowed to say
well so i've made money from originally
selling out on weird wells and then
working on other nft collections i've
also made money but most of my money has
come from that the fact that ethereum's
price is going up rapidly but it was
going up rapidly
and i'm probably if i sold all my nfts
at the high end sold all my crypto at a
good price i'll probably sit and be
sitting on around one million dollars
damn
you so you're a millionaire
you're a 13 year old millionaire
yeah you're an inspiration to all of all
the other 13 year olds and also your
teachers at school probably like damn
this kid got more cash than me how do i
do it
have any of them ask you have any of
them ask you what they should do
yes so i think i was waiting in the car
park at the end of the day to get picked
up and one of my teachers just
told me that they invested
i think
some money and have already made
50 like 500 pounds
and they're absolutely mind blown yeah
and then you were like yes chump change
kid
right you're like you're like now the
tables have turned teacher
benjamin what did you do when you
figured out you were worth a million
dollars
i haven't really been gone like flexing
everyone on twitter i just
want to stay humble and keep on learning
i like that
somebody uh somebody in the chat said uh
benjamin stole your girl
all right buddy anything else that you
got for us
yes so the last section i want to talk
about is
three stories in the nft space that
caught my attention
please tell me the three stories
but before i go into that i want to just
share a bit of alpha with you all today
please you've got you've got alpha leak
arms you're going alpha league on the
audience
yes damn pete you wanna be the favorite
guest there's nobody else that comes on
here so i'm gonna give you guys some
alpha go ahead what's the alpha
okay prepare to be mind blown
so if you bought a board ape for 200
and then collected all the subsequent
air drops like the dogs and the mutant
apes and the recent eight coin token you
would be sitting on an invest on a
return of over half a million dollars
and that's at the low end don't forget
that some of these rare apes have sold
for millions of dollars
and that probably makes board apes the
best investment in history
so basically the idea is
if you bought the actual asset itself
then you got air dropped everything else
and that led to a huge financial uh gain
for the people who had held it uh and
then also there was appreciation of the
ape itself
yes
yeah that's pretty crazy
i feel like people don't understand the
air drops what do you think about air
drops
yeah i think air drops are good free
money food money is always good
but that's what the socialists say too
the thing is um the holders of these
apes are not only air drops money but
also knowledge of sensors getting these
new
tokens the eightfold token the new nfts
they taught people in a way about erc20s
and
erc721s and different contracts so that
was also another side to it
yeah it's uh it's pretty crazy how you
get uh
um
the air drops but also uh can you stake
nfts are people doing that yet
yes some collections you can't stake you
stake it and then uh what about like
fractional uh components of it the
people have done that
yes so i think there is um one company
that specializes in fractionalizing your
nfts so you can have one mft split into
40 different lfcs and sell that off to
different people
and then lastly is uh are people lending
against them yet
there must be some people that are
lending against it but i haven't heard
of anyone yeah definitely somebody's got
to be uh got to be lending against it
right
there's no way that people have millions
of dollars worth of uh nfts and they're
not trying to get
um
some kind of loan using it as collateral
i'd imagine right john yeah yeah i think
so too the fractional ownership stuff's
cool you like that well they do it in um
assets today right traditional assets
today right trading cards jerseys
sporting goods memorabilia anything
right fractional ownership in a rare
thing
yeah i agree
um the uh somebody in the chat said if
anyone here loses money then they can
tell their lawyer that they uh lost
money taking financial advice from a 13
year old
yeah this is this isn't financial advice
no financial i said in the chat very
specifically nothing we say is financial
advice yeah well we actually don't have
advice at all yeah we just like to have
fun on the internet benjamin what what
uh what time is it there
5 20 5 20. so so we do this at like noon
every other week we're going to be good
as after school
yes
all right perfect i finished school at i
think four o'clock at four o'clock yeah
the well you gotta tell you gotta tell
the teachers hey i gotta i gotta go i
gotta get out of here i gotta go on the
best business show and then get them all
to watch right and then they'll be
sitting there and they'll be teaching
you
about things during the day and then at
five o'clock you'll be teaching them
things about how to make money
i'm shocked that more teachers don't ask
you
well
yeah
they they don't really talk about it
much well i would if i was a 45 year old
teacher and a 13 year old had a million
bucks it was in my class i wouldn't talk
about it either you walk in the
teacher's conference room and they're
like he did what
they probably want to know how to make
money too that's what i'm saying i'm i'm
shocked that more especially the younger
teachers aren't asking him how to do it
or what they should think about or you
know can you explain nfts to the class
i'm surprised no one gave you money and
was like hey can you turn this into more
money please
you want the teachers to convince them
to start a fund
i'm surprised no one tried to convince
them to take it
i don't know did have you told your
classmates about nfts
well
they as i said before they didn't talk
about it much but at the time they did
ask me oh what is this and then i would
explain it and then they were like uh
okay but i don't think they understood
it
yeah well and also i i guess part of it
too is uh uh they gotta have interest
from like a technical standpoint
that makes sense
all right listen i'm super excited i i
feel uh i don't know why but i feel
proud of you like i feel like you've
done a great job and you continue to
kind of push forward you're still
learning you're doing a lot of different
stuff uh you and your brother are are
enjoying it are you doing this with uh
your your dad and your mom and
everything that they're excited about
this too
yeah they're all so excited my dad's
gonna keep on teaching me
and we're going to keep on doing our
coding challenges and my mom's going to
keep on supporting me yeah your dad
gives you coding challenges
yes so there's a website online called
code wars
and every day we do one coding challenge
on that website oh wow
and uh uh who's better you or your
brother
well we've had this debate before and i
think
kind of we kind of settle it that we're
both as good as each other uh yeah that
sounds like a cop out
yeah well my brother this you know these
are my brothers right and there's two
more so there's five of us total if we
ever had a debate about who was better
at coding we would have punched each
other
[Laughter]
don't do that don't hit your brother
that's bad your parents will be mad
don't uh don't do that uh i'd still beat
john's butt though everyone would just
say they're the best yeah of course well
i am the best so i would be telling the
truth you guys would be lying all right
benjamin listen thank you so much for
coming on i'm super excited we're going
to be doing this uh every other week or
so and uh
you know the audience when you said you
had alpha to leak they got super excited
so maybe we'll uh we'll come back with
some more uh some more ideas uh when you
come back next time
oh
do you mute yourself
yep right buddy sounds good see you
later see you benjamin see you later bye